sinon c'est la bonne idée qui paraît
logique mais il fallait bien quelqu'un
commence et c'est formidable que le
conseil départemental et cette
initiative en apport aux antilles la
réunion est un petit peu en retrait pour
qu'on a rattrapé le retard on a su
justement développé un concept se
livrent pour pouvoir la réunion
on sera également l'occasion de se
servir de la boutique de l'île de la
réunion en quatre deux réunions
commerciales
c'est à l'image de notre île un crayonné
en france qui aimeraient peut-être
justement lors les affinités
savoir tout ça existe venir chercher
un petit bouddha régnant la bonne idée
qu'il n'avait pas encore été faite voilà
comment est qualifié unanimement la
boutique île de la réunion du
département de la réunion
la diversité des couleurs et la
luminosité réunionnaise tranche dans la
nuit parisienne mais lens utilitaire
réorganise et derrière vous a lieu après
la diffusion à seulement les réguliers
sur une centaine de mètres carrés de
vitrine au coeur de paris dont le 4e
arrondissement dédiés à l'excellence des
produits réunionnais une vision en grand
qui fait du bien et complètement un
excellent choix parce que c'est un point
de convergence naturelle avec la
proximité de beaubourg
c'est un autre exercice y va ce thème
l'hôtel de ville est clairement ya
probablement un développement de
fréquentation qui sera liée à la
localiser
cette boutique selon l'insee plus de
cent cinq mille natif de la réunion
vivent sur le territoire métropolitain
ce qui représente 30% de la population
domaine autant de relais de l'identité
réunionnaise qui passe par ces
produits-là touristes c'est de la
culture c'est l'humain c'est de les
changer l'expérience et c'est de la
nourriture donc à plein de choses
ils font d'abord la envie de venir à
l'aréna une inauguration convivial où
les produits locaux sublimé par un chef
étoilé combler les 150 convives des
produits qui ont besoin de cet espace
pour leur développement
je pense qu'on est aujourd'hui dans une
logique où l'exportation de biens clé
pour nous en particulier sur des
produits haut de gamme c'est vraiment en
allant chercher de la valeur ajoutée
qu'on sera capable d'exporter nos savoir
faire est de mettre en valeur notre
culture
quand je pense qu'une belle vitrine est
très utile aux rayonnements à des
savoir-faire de lille c'est donc une
brute
en musique et devant ce que la réunion
fait de meilleurs tels que les meubles
en bois de goyavier ces acteurs
économiques ont pu passer un moment
plaisir un instant où chacun est fier de
montrer son attachement à notre île le
meilleur matériau
rond capital colonna le premier capital
comme menacée
est-ce que là les portes de son âge sa
terre ils portent sont végétales il
colle sa roche volcanique c'est
peut-être ce volcan de sa passion il
pose ce qu'il sait faire avec la messe
était dite et tout ça avec son pack
payable et des tests qui s'est
transformée ils font l'amour sony ait la
moindre chance
et puis c'est superbe pour communier
avec les malheurs de lannion impression
à la convivialité le partage la chaleur
aussi du fait le réunionnais et et pour
noirs contre la marée noire et nous
pensons que je crois que c'est mon
actualité airs est toujours plein de
petites initiatives de de fer rock de la
restauration une vitrine mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin de fédérer
les institutions avec le monde
économique et avec le monde culturel et
le patrimoine et bamert notre miss
france elle fait partie aujourd'hui
et de manière indélébile de notre
patrimoine elle moi je crois que c'est
tout cela qui fait que nous pouvons
avoir une boutique de la radio ce soit
nos vitrines de la mer au 21 rue du
renard dont le 4e arrondissement
les produits réunionnais peuvent
maintenant être ambitieux sur le
territoire métropolitain